Why is Poland actually extremely hard to invade?
Although Poland has been invaded on practically
all sides throughout history
and has a very flat geography,
it would not be so easy to invade it today. Here's why.
The first reason is that Poland only has one main enemy
Russia. If Russia was to invade Poland,
it would either have to invade through Belarus
or through Kalinangrad,
which would require flawless coordination from Russia.
On top of that,
Finland just joined NATO,
which would additionally
challenge Russian supply lines in the Baltic Sea.
And most importantly,
Poland is a member of NATO.
So if Poland was attacked,
it would have much more support today
than it would have had in past invasions.
On top of that,
Poland has made major weapons deals with the US
and South Korea,
which has LED to Poland spending 2.2% of its GDP
be on military expenses.
And furthermore,
Poland is planning on increasing it to 2.5% by 2030.
So if there were an invasion of Poland,
Poland would be prepared.